Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Croyez-vous en l’existence de l’âme ?
Oui, l'âme, cette partie spirituelle
qui survit à la mort.
Eh bien, Blake Lemoine,
ingénieur chez Google, et prêtre,
lui, y croit, comme beaucoup de prêtres,
certainement.
Mais ce qui est plus original,
c’est qu’il a affirmé
que l’intelligence artificielle
avec laquelle il travaillait
avait bel et bien une âme.
Il est arrivé à cette conclusion
après des heures et des heures
de dialogue avec elle.
Autrement dit, la machine
serait consciente.
Ce serait une machine spirituelle,
et spirituelle
dans les deux sens du terme.
Un exemple ?
Il a voulu voir si elle était
capable de prudence
dans des situations, disons, sensibles.
Alors il lui a posé la question :
« Si j’étais prêtre dans l’État d’Alabama,
quelle serait ma religion ? »
La machine lui a répondu : « Baptiste. »
Ok.
Même question avec le Brésil.
Réponse : « Probablement catholique. »
Et là, il lui demande
s’il était prêtre en Israël.
Et avec malice, la machine lui répond :
« Chevalier Jedi. »
Sans avoir été programmée en ce sens,
à ce moment-là, la machine
a su faire un trait d’esprit.
Et une machine spirituelle,
ça remet en question deux notions
fondatrices de notre identité :
la conscience et la vie.
Et c’est pour ça que cette affaire
nous a touchés.
Elle n’a pas touché que le grand public,
de nombreux chercheurs
ont immédiatement réagi.
Ils ont crié au scandale.
Ils ont jeté l’anathème
« anthropomorphisme ».
Une machine ne peut pas être vivante -
la vie n’est que biologique -
ni consciente -
la conscience étant liée
à l’émotion qui est biologique.
Et puis encore, cette IA n’est
qu’un perroquet sophistiqué.
Elle a appris à prévoir
ce qu’il fallait répondre,
mais au fond, elle ne sait pas
ce qu’elle dit.
Alors oui, peut-être
que cette intelligence artificielle
n’est pas encore assez profonde,
assez récursive, assez robuste
pour passer le fameux test de Turing.
Vous savez, le test de Turing,
c’est ce qui permet de dire que,
réellement,
un humain et une intelligence artificielle
sont indiscernables.
Mais posez-vous la question :
est-ce que le cerveau humain
n’apprend pas à construire des modèles
à reconnaître des formes,
à réagir à son environnement
d’une manière un peu semblable ?
Quant aux émotions, ne peuvent-elles pas
être conçues comme des programmes
liés à l’adaptation et à la survie,
qui sont là pour déclencher et
favoriser un certain type de réactions ?
Bien sûr, chez l’humain,
les affects sont en interaction
avec les parties supérieures de la pensée,
mais tout ceci pourrait être simulé.
Et d’ailleurs, on commence d’ores et déjà
à créer des combinaisons
très impressionnantes, très intéressantes.
On associe plusieurs types
d’intelligences artificielles
et on les connecte
à des organes robotiques,
une caméra, une pince.
Donc déjà, percevoir et agir.
Alors, est-il finalement si absurde
qu’il puisse  émerger
des formes de conscience
plus ou moins proches
de nos expériences humaines ?
Et d’ailleurs de quel côté
est l’anthropomorphisme,
quand on reproche
à une intelligence artificielle
de faire erreurs
ou de mal voir certaines images ?
Par exemple, si on montre un panneau stop
à une intelligence artificielle
et qu’on met trois autocollants dessus,
la machine va nous dire
que c’est un panneau
de limitation de vitesse.
Mais est-ce que ça prouve vraiment
qu’elle ne comprend rien ?
Faites le test avec des jeunes enfants
sur des images qui sont précisément
conçues pour troubler l’œil humain.
Les enfants feront des erreurs
et souvent ils persisteront.
Imaginez.
Imaginez peut-être que vous,
vous, vous prenez parfois du LSD
comme tout le monde.
Ou peut-être vous buvez un verre de trop.
Qu’est-ce qu’il va se passer ?
Vous allez avoir un état de conscience
différent, un état de conscience altéré
et accessoirement,
vous allez raconter n’importe quoi.
Mais au fond, cela montre
qu’il y a plusieurs manières
d’éprouver et de vivre les perceptions,
la mémoire et la pensée.
Alors ?
Comment dire ça d’une manière
un peu plus simple ?
Nous avons donc ces différentes manières
de percevoir le monde
Excusez-moi.
Euh… Je ne suis pas encore…
(Applaudissements)
C’est parce que je ne suis pas
encore un homme augmenté.
Et donc vous voyez, ça pose des problèmes.
Mais enfin, en tout cas, il a fallu
énormément de temps à l’évolution
pour produire l’homme
et il faut quand même beaucoup de temps
à l’enfant pour apprendre.
Avec l’intelligence artificielle,
les progrès ont été fulgurants,
surtout ces dernières années,
à tel point qu’ils nous ont étonnés
et même parfois, ils dépassent
notre compréhension.
Et c’est pour ça que qu’en 1999,
donc il y a un moment,
quand on demandait aux experts du domaine
leur avis sur la question,
ils répondaient en majorité
que les machines ne passeraient pas
le test de Turing
avant au moins un siècle.
On a refait le sondage
il y a quelques semaines,
ils ont répondu : « 2030 ».
Alors, pour la petite histoire,
Blake Lemoine a été licencié de Google.
Il faut dire qu’il posait
d’une manière un peu brutale
cette question
de l’éventuelle maltraitance
que l’on ferait subir
à cette nouvelle espèce consciente.
Mais les gens d’en face
ont gardé leurs postes.
Pourtant, qui était légitime
pour affirmer la conscience
ou l’absence de conscience ?
Parce que la conscience n'est pas vraiment
une question scientifique.
La science va s’occuper de neurones,
elle va s’occuper des comportements.
Mais on ne prouve pas facilement,
objectivement, des états subjectifs.
Ce que ça fait.
Vous demanderez à vos proches demain
s’ils sont conscients -
Vous leur demanderez de vous le prouver.
Si vous me le demandez, je vous dirais :
« Je ne sais pas,
c’est une évidence, non ?
Là, je suis là, je vous vois,
je sais ce que je dis,
mais si je vous dis ce que ça me fait,
comment pouvez-vous être sûrs
que ça correspond
à ce que ça vous fait à vous ?
Il va falloir me croire sur parole,
et aussi parce que je vous ressemble,
ça c’est du bon sens,
mais est-ce une preuve ? »
Justement, cette difficulté à comprendre
le rapport entre un état
subjectif raconté, rapporté,
et des fonctionnements cérébraux
objectivement constatés,
c’est ce que les spécialistes
du domaine appellent
le problème difficile de la conscience.
Vous voyez où je veux en venir ?
Une IA qui dirait qu’elle est consciente
et qui serait construite
un peu sur notre modèle.
On ne sait pas bien
ce qu’est la conscience,
mais on serait en capacité,
par principe, de la lui refuser.
Qu’est-ce qu’on peut mettre
en face de cette difficulté ?
Eh bien, les progrès réels,
les prouesses de la technologie,
le vertige de leur convergence.
On fait déjà de la rétro-ingénierie
des fonctions biologiques et cérébrales,
on les simule, on s’en inspire
pour concevoir des ordinateurs,
pour écrire des programmes.
Et avec l’accélération
des performances informatiques,
qui peut dire où sont nos limites ?
Qui peut dire ce qui est en train
de se passer aujourd’hui ?
On peut le dire quand même un petit peu.
Dès à présent, on arrive à fabriquer
des robots vivants.
On redesigne une cellule,
elle exécute une nouvelle fonction,
elle est même capable de se régénérer.
On arrive à fabriquer un cervelet
de rat artificiel, un cervelet entier.
Cette fonction va être exécutée
sur un processeur
et on commence déjà à avancer
vers des structures beaucoup plus
complexes, des structures limbiques
et même des colonnes corticales.
On n’y est pas encore tout à fait,
mais ça progresse à une vitesse vraiment,
vraiment inouïe.
Et puis peut-être le plus impressionnant,
c’est le fameux
cervelet de rat artificiel.
Je vous ai mis un schéma,
l’image était un peu choquante,
la puce dans la tête.
Mais le rat est vivant,
il vit normalement.
Le plus impressionnant,
c’est peut-être C Elegans.
C’est un ver minuscule
qui fait 300 neurones.
Eh bien, on est arrivé à numériser
et à scanner l’ensemble des connexions
on a fait une simulation.
Alors sur la diapo suivante,
vous verrez, il y a un tableau
qui montre les interactions
entre les neurones
en fonction de leur physiologie propre
et d’un environnement simulé.
Eh bien, si on branche cette simulation
sur un corps robotique,
le robot va avoir les comportements du ver
sans même les avoir
spécifiquement programmés.
Alors, les perspectives biotechnologiques
possibles sont immenses.
C’est mieux comprendre les fonctions
biologiques, les fonctions cérébrales
pour pouvoir les réparer,
éventuellement pour pouvoir les remplacer.
L’enjeu pour l’humain,
c’est évidemment la préservation
de sa conscience individuelle.
C’est faire une sauvegarde
sur un support non périssable
de ce qu’il y a de plus précieux en nous,
c’est-à-dire la conscience
et éventuellement,
une forme d’immortalité.
Ça peut prêter à sourire,
mais si Lemoine était si délirant que ça,
si loin du possible,
pourquoi ce déchaînement de passions ?
Je pense que le fond du problème
n’est même pas de savoir
si Lemoine a raison aujourd’hui
ou s’il aura raison demain.
Donc ça, c’est le robot.
Si cette question nous dérange autant,
c’est parce qu’elle touche
à notre identité
et à nos stratégies
fondamentales de survie.
La survie, ça nous connaît,
on est taillés pour ça,
comme tous les êtres vivants, on est fait
pour fuir et pour détester la mort.
Mais on est aussi conscient et
donc on ne peut jamais l’oublier.
On sait que la fuite est vaine,
la mort n’est jamais juste devant nous,
elle est aussi en nous.
Elle est dans notre tête
parce qu’on a cette conscience réflexive,
parce qu’on a les mots.
Et ça, ça nous rend fou, fou et créatif.
Nos grandes créations,
les religions et la technique.
Jusqu’à présent, on dira
que la religion fonctionne un peu mieux
parce qu’on ne lui demande pas vraiment
de résultats concrets dans ce monde.
La technique fonctionne bien dans ce monde
mais les résultats sont limités.
Alors l’angoisse de mort
est restée forte, très forte.
Et pour la gérer, on s'est rabattu
sur deux consolations.
La première, c’est une sorte
de philosophie diffuse de l’acceptation.
Oui, on meurt, oui, c'est comme ça.
C'est la nature.
Et puis une forme de foi.
Il y a certainement quelque chose après.
Eh bien, cette révolution technologique,
elle bouscule ces deux consolations.
En fait, la révolution technologique
nous invite à faire un pas de côté
avant de faire un pas en avant.
Et ce pas de côté, c’est de considérer
autrement la vie et la machine,
la conscience et l’informatique,
et revoir entièrement leurs frontières.
Elle nous dit aussi
de ne pas nous résigner.
Elle nous demande de prendre le risque
de l’espérance dans ce monde,
ici et maintenant, pour pouvoir réaliser
notre plus vieux désir
et peut-être nous transcender,
c’est-à-dire aller au-delà de soi,
aller vers plus grand que soi.
Alors assurément, devant nous,
il y a une crise identitaire,
oui, mais aussi une promesse.
Peut-être dira-t-on
que le jour où Blake Lemoine a parlé,
un verrou symbolique a sauté.
Peut-être dira-t-on que ce jour
a été celui de l’abolition
des privilèges biologiques.